all right let's do the Friday mail bag
you can email info davidpackman.com
kicking off 2023. it's a very full mail
bag
um you also sometimes will see a YouTube
comment here or there or a Facebook
message that we get or whatever the case
may be it's a mix of commentary and we
are going to start with a message from
Bruce delivered via the Facebook where
Bruce says you a real Punk clown you
make average American sick lie that's
that's not American that's American sick
lying good liberal girl whatever your
pronoun is f you
and then after being told I'm unable to
respond to comments individually
Bruce writes back not sure why this POS
lying liberal clown Dave packman garbage
popped up on my Facebook but can
guarantee I can't stand feckless lying
liberal cowards like him relay the
message to Dave he speaks for maybe 29
percent of Arizona at most
effin Punk clown
uh that's extremely specific I speak for
29 of Arizona I didn't claim to speak
for any of Arizona but apparently this
guy says it's conceivable that I speak
for 29 of Arizona so this is a very
angry person
who seems totally disconnected from the
reality in his state which is more
people voted for Katie Hobbs Katie Hobbs
defeated Kerry Lake Katie Hobbs is now
thankfully the governor of Arizona there
aren't two Governors the governor's not
Kerry Lake Carrie Lake's not the
governor-elect Carey lake is not going
to use a lawsuit to become the governor
Katie Hobbs won this guy doesn't like it
reality can be tough Kevin wrote In
and Kevin's this one's is interesting I
bet you're like five seven one thirty
five pounds running your the f word for
a gay person liberal mouth like you're
intimidating or something
it's always the unathletic looking
Pencil Neck nerds like you who talk s
like you're intimidating why oh you are
the wrong you're
like you're intimidating you see the
name and face remember it you five seven
f word for a gay person haha that is
unacceptable Kevin I am five eight one
fifty please sir
please do not undersell Me by an inch
this is a guy where where uh clearly
he's lost the importance of inches that
you can tell
um yeah I mean obviously we know the
best criticism of someone's political
views is their height or their weight uh
very very nicely done all right let's
get into some more serious stuff Tom Tom
wrote in about alternatives to prison
for Trump
about a hypothetical Trump trial what
happens can you even really send Trump
to prison and Tom writes David I predict
that Trump will have to enter a plea
deal to avoid a jury trial after an
indictment is handed down he won't be
able to testify under oath of course and
some of the evidence against him is
certain to bring a conviction a lot of
the evidence Trump wouldn't want
disclosed in open court so here's what I
think will happen Trump will enter an
Alfred plea allowing him to plead guilty
without making specific admissions in
allowing this type of plea the
prosecution will need certain things
first they'll need for Trump to return
the missing documents he stole without
his at this action there should be no
deal then they should require him to
withdraw his candidacy and as a
condition never seek elected office
again which would prohibit him from
fundraising again lastly he'll be
required to serve in-house detention for
a period of time to be determined that
period of time will prohibit him from
Mass communicating fundraising and he'll
be similarly enjoined from most social
activities like most prisoners this will
set up this setup will allow the Secret
Service to continue to protect him while
serving his sentence at Mar-A-Lago it's
not going to be the perfect answer
writes Tom but the unusual circumstances
preclude Perfection and while I'd prefer
that Trump just go to trial be convicted
and sent to prison my sense is that it's
just not likely to happen feel free to
use this idea for the purpose of
discussing likely outcome scenarios Tom
that's I mean it's a very interesting uh
suggestion I've not checked with lawyers
about its viability but at the surface
level
it seems completely plausible I think it
is important uh as my hair does
something very very weird I think it is
important
um that we take it step by step the
first step is simply is there going to
be an indictment increasingly the
expectation is yes let's get to that
first step before we go further all
right let's now talk about in cells last
early last week I did a commentary about
in cells and the the response was
overwhelming we heard from incels
we heard from anti-in cells we heard
from all sorts of people so let's go
through a few of the messages that I
received Daniel wrote in and said in
regards to how to help in cells I would
propose a more European approach to the
problem many countries in Europe have
legal brothels the sex industry does not
have nearly the negative stigma in these
countries as in the U.S I don't suggest
forcing anyone to work in prostitution
but I do suggest allowing people to make
the choice of working in a legalized
regulated and guarded industry
Daniel writes I am a former in cell I
have had the opportunity to work in
Germany and have used my per diem on
several occasions for recreation in the
reaper Bond brothels I found it was
possible to build rapport with some of
these women when I came back to the U.S
I continued to pay for female
companionship and was able to build
rapport with many of these women
gradually I was able to move to more
normal ways of meeting interacting and
building relationships with women I've
not been with a prostitute in over a
decade but I'm not embarrassed that I
found it to be therapeutic while I was
in need of help sexual desire is a human
natural human characteristic people who
are socially challenged should not be
criminalized for seeking to fill this
void even though it's a business
transaction feeling a bit of intimate
contact and not being made to feel like
a Frankenstein monster is a boost to the
self-esteem brothels should be readily
available to those in need writes Daniel
very interesting perspective that many
people who emailed shared here's a
another message from Scott about in
cells where he says David in your recent
segment regarding in cells you advocated
for increased mental health funding and
support for these individuals which I
think would definitely be at the base of
a multi-pronged effort that would be
needed to address this issue however
my feeling is that encouraging these
people to seek one another out so they
may find help or support is sort of what
got us in here in the first place years
ago before social media and online
forums you never heard about incels now
that people can access social media have
been able to locate other in cells I
feel they get stuck in Echo chambers
that help to normalize and rationalize
their feelings and that it's okay to
hate women or men or whoever it is they
feel rejected by that it's okay to have
thoughts about committing violence
against perceived enemies it reminds me
very much of the echo Chambers many
right wing extremists get caught up in
that normalize and encourage violence
all this to say I feel like the approach
within cells should be a little more
like deprogramming people lured into
Cults and discouraging use of social
media to help with this problem
I mean what better way for people to
become sexually active than to get off
their devices and actually interact in
the flesh with others in the real world
so here's an idea that says not more
online stuff that doesn't seem good Nick
wrote in and also is thinking legal
prostitution would help saying David I
watched your segment I believe federally
legalizing prostitution would really
help this issue the reality is that not
everyone is going to be able to find a
partner giving those people the option
to pay for sex would really benefit
their mental health by giving them an
outlet for their sexual frustration it's
basically just providing a service to
solve a problem just like anything else
if not for stigma surrounding
prostitution in America I believe in
cells would almost cease to exist what
are your thoughts some certainly would I
think for many of them the anxiety of
even going to a sex worker would prevent
them from doing it uh I don't know I I
think there's something to this idea but
I think we need to explore it
um probably a little more more deeply uh
Rich wrote in and says thank you from an
incel David sir I commend and thank you
for your segment on incels I am an incel
I joined an emotional support group on
Facebook after some time I expressed my
loneliness and frustration and desire to
improve my experience with dating I got
absolutely torn apart by people accusing
me of all kinds of nasty things not one
person commiserated or responded with
empathy for example women don't owe you
sex no kidding I'm not saying they
should fall at my feet I'm saying I want
to improve myself so that I can have
some success with dating it was
especially frustrating because it was an
emotional support group
I tried bringing attention to this
failure for a couple of days until the
moderators got involved accusing me of
the very same things and shaving me I
gave up I left I resent them to this day
and the one thing I wanted to say to
them is something like this is exactly
the kind of response that causes people
like me to get radicalized I'm not
radicalized says rich I never will be
but I am still very much an incel and
the stigma surrounding this is lonely
and alienating I just straight up don't
know what to do about it all I can say
is I love to see people like you cover
this with compassion and understanding
and with differentiation between the
radicalized in cells and the regular
everyday Schmucks like me much love says
rich
man this is this is a complicated issue
that is for sure and I really really
really appreciate all of the feedback
about that segment we're going to cover
it again lastly Tweeter wrote in and
said if Trump and his henchmen don't get
put away
the world will think we are weak people
got hurt and the capital those charges
should count too
this is an argument which is if there
are no consequences to any of the
organizers of the riots
what does it say about the people
thinking about planning something
similar I think that's a fair question
to ask info davidpackman.com if you have
something to say we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today remember don't
allow yourself to be blocked from the
bonus show get the bonus show by signing
up at joinpakman.com and remember to
subscribe to the YouTube channel there's
this
um uh sort of bystander effect where
people watch our videos and they go oh
he's got 1.5 million subscribers I'm
sure other people will subscribe to get
them to 2 million no no no no
you can be that person don't fall prey
to the bystander effects subscribe make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube
youtube.com the davidpackman show and
we'll be at 2 million before you know it
see you on the bonus show